soir où je suis je voudrais partager
avec vous des histoires de bouffon quand
on parle de bouffon en français en
général ce n'est pas positive si haut si
vous dites quel bouffon civile à ce
n'est pas un compliment mais le bouffon
c'est aussi un style théâtral puissant
qui m'a donné des outils pour survivre
comme artiste et dans ma vie personnelle
en état artistes et chorégraphes la
danse contemporaine
j'aurais jamais imaginé l'impact et la
dimension de mon un ciment de bouffon
dans le monde
je suis sous plus alors on peut dire que
j'ai eu une carrière depuis 42 ans était
entre la danse contemporaine et le
bouffon et mesdames et messieurs je ne
suis pas ici ce soir pour vous parler de
la danse n'est plus tôt le bouffon et
comment ça transforme
artistiquement professionnellement elle
même personnellement un individu alors
par curiosité
s'il vous plaît lever la main si vous
avez déjà suivi un atelier de bouffon il
n'a une personne six mois que
l'entraîner
bon courage
alors c'est quoi le bouffon basée dans
la tradition médiévale le bouffon
explore divers personnages spéciaux
divisé à quatre familles la première
famille c'est les corps énorme cette
famille ils sont très fiers ou montrer
qu est ce qu ils vont le faire un temps
sans gêne
la deuxième famille c'est le bossu aussi
fière sa bosse ce personnage est plus
humble et aussi le quêteur
professionnels
compostelle
qu'est ce que par hasard vous êtes
célibataire non je suis mort est ce que
ta race à vous avez de l'argent c'est le
possible troisième famille
l'aîné ce personnage c'est un personnage
de s'amuser à jouer mais quand vous
voyez ça peut être claustrophobe assez
caustique le nay le personnage de neige
où beaucoup y aime beaucoup placoter à
savoir toutes les affaires des autres et
la relation entre le n 1 et le grand
prêtre cette relation très important
parce que le nain toujours incertitude
au grand raid est évidemment le grand
prêtre
ce personnage est très différent que les
autres font parce que c'est un
personnage plus fanatiques et quand jean
5 ça je dis toujours à mes élèves de
imaginé que tu as 12 pieds de hauteur
très très grand ce personnage il sourit
pas comme les autres bouffons les autres
fondre tous de très exagéré parce que ce
personnage est très fanatique même qu'un
jury ayant comme la douleur aussi le
grand prédit qu'il y a le pouvoir de
livrer le message de dieu à l'homme
on sait bien que c'est pas vrai
mais les bouffons iliad or ces
personnages là alors qu'il considère
toujours le grand prêtre comme le leader
de leur famille alors dans ce
coffre-fort comme habitude ya juste une
grande pride
les bouffons et r rejeter et forcés de
vivre en marge de la société pour leur
propre survie
alors pour leurs besoins
des fois été obligé tout coller ensemble
de rentrer dans les villes les villages
pour voler la bouffe du linge des choses
qu'ils avaient besoin
mais le petit buzz le monde marche ps
wallon dont alors je reste fidèle à la
tradition net vous font comme les
maîtres nous l'ont appris
mais les flots hausse de la danse
contemporaine est faut dire aussi la
culture italienne
j'ai poussé beaucoup plus le côté
physique et aussi l'attitude causer du
bouffon plus loin que mes prédécesseurs
alors comment j'ai découvert le bouffon
tout a commencé en 1981 je venais de
déménager à vancouver où j'ai débuté ma
carrière en danse contemporaine aussi
mon nouveau colocataire marcel il venait
de revenir au canada après avoir passé
quatre ans à paris où il ya la vie à
étudier avec les grands maîtres mais sur
jacques lecoq et me suffit les colis
alors c'est sûr avec un peu temps on est
devenus de grands amis
et évidemment j'ai entendu parler
beaucoup du bouffon et lui la danse
alors manei tpr et il était prêt à faire
son projet qui me parlait depuis
longtemps et il y avait planifié à faire
ça à l'extérieur à le marché de grandes
manoeuvres ont couvert alors c'est
certain ce jour là il fallait voir
qu'est ce que l'homme a parlé tout à
l'heure alors j'ai parti en vélo et je
m'arrête sur le pont je regarde encore l
intrigue avec le bouffon commence j'ai
vu une famille de bouffon ou en groupe
qu'est-ce que tout vêtus des costumes
colorés avec des grands sourires et à
regarder le public avait pris fixe tout
coller ensemble ils bougeaient pas
longtemps mais c'était les grilles qui
m'a fait d'approché à les regarder tout
un clou tout un quiz éclaté à
l'improvisation visé des parodies
hilarantes limonest et s'arrêter et se
déplacer notre partie du marché se
coller ensemble avec des souris
satisfait de tout ce qui vient enfin un
peu sournois aussi et point fixe et
recommencer le spectacle de nouveau en
regardant ça j'ai compris la connexion
entre le bouffon est la danse c'était le
mouvement est aussi jeu j'ai vu
peut-être un autre phase
améliorer mais habilités de performance
comme interprète la danse je les suis
dit tout l'après-midi et l affaire
j'étais convaincu que j'avais quelque
chose à apprendre à explorer cette
nouvelle découverte alors j'ai rejoint
le truc de beauf haut et j'ai tout fait
jusqu'à deux jours que marcel est décédé
et oui malheureusement notre leader
grande amie est tombée très malade de
son lait à l'hôpital il m'a passé son
bâton et m'a dit massimo tu vas
continuer mon estime à près jusque là
encore je suis juste vous raconter ça à
l'époque je me sentais pas prêt ou avoir
des facultés et remplissez ces énormes
signé qui s'était quand même un bon lot
6 pieds 5
or on est en france m 95
alors j'ai dit oui à mon grand ami pour
le rendre heureux mais je savais pas
encore qu'est ce que j'aurais fait avec
tout ça trois ans passe depuis qui est
décédé l école de danse contemporaine de
montréal me contacter pour enseigner le
bouffo a eu huit filles qui t'apprennent
étudie à l'école d'un ce temps là qui
était de très bonne technicienne mais
pas fort en présence sur scène alors
avec le processus du du bouffon
j'ai travaillé un doux avec ses fils a
et j'ai réussi à améliorer les habiletés
de performance a remarquablement alors
les deux directives sont venus nous voir
les résultats et j'étais assis entre les
deux il regarder les filles il me
regarde et me garder les filles regardé
comme un défi je dis aux ja pas ça
tout à coup une des lectrices ti pa di
martino depuis ce temps-là meco de
bouffon sont des cours obligatoires d'un
kart école professionnelle de danse
contemporaine au canada y est
et aussi c'est le coup chouchou du
soleil alors pourquoi j'enseigne le
bouffon
je m'ennuie jamais jamais jamais chaque
fois que je fais le même chose c'est
toujours différent
pourquoi parce qu'on est des individus
différents timidement différend semble
si jamais par m6 filetage deux fois de
suite ça sera une autre expérience aussi
merveilleux que la première alors ça ça
ça contribue beaucoup à maintenir ce
travail est très sain et toujours le fun
la deuxième chose pour maquetter pente à
ce que le bouffon n'y a pas de barrière
linguistique et utilise un langage
universel
c'est très physique il ya certainement
qu'ils ont peur d'ouvrir les yeux
alors faut préciser que que quelqu'un
qui fait qu'il veut faire le bouffon
doit être ferme après à s'abandonner à
ce type de théâtre physique iq routes
est la troisième choses s'améliorent la
connaissance de soi mais ne veut pas ça
va le faire tous se sent vraiment
content et je pourrais pas demander peut
rien de plus quand j'enseigne l'élève de
devenir meilleur qu'il ait déjà
et ainsi le bouffon est pour tout le
monde artiste et non artistes souvent le
soleil me fait enseigner et stages de
bouffon corporatif 18 bombardier et les
grands grain compagnie c'est pas des
artistes mais ils sont aussi
intéressants et bien plus drôle que les
artistes
en conclusion la vraie raison que je
vais à sonner d'enseigner le bouffon
parce que ça transforme le monde et ça
laisse une impression positive et
permanente
le bouffon demande
les participants de rire de soi-même
avant de faire des parodies les autres
et une fois acquis atteint le plaisir de
faire ça
c'est là que la transformation commence
et je suis toujours eu des témoignages
ce à chaque fois alors pour terminer
s'il vous plaît lever la main si
maintenant vous et tentez de cfa le
bouffer
merci beaucoup merci